my greatest trick convincing my wife we
need a Nintendo switch for my kids
welcome to a very special edition of The
Apprentice White House edition on this
show you don't get fired you try to get
hired what a twist right right right
the job only the most powerful staff job
in all of Washington chief of staff to
the President of the United States
pretty pretty big now before we get the
contestants let's remember how we got
here
Donald Trump's first chief of staff was
named Reince Priebus he was the chairman
of the Republican National Committee and
someone the establishment thought might
be able to tame Trump's worst instincts
Oh anywho Priebus was gone within six
months of taking the job fired by tweet
while the president was sitting on the
tarmac in Washington on a rainy Friday
night could that scene possibly have
gotten more depressing in previous place
came John Kelly in the decorated
military man who had been leading the
Department of Homeland Security and who
was tapped by Trump to bring order and
direction to an order Lucinda rection
'less Whitehouse Kelly tried to do that
limiting Trump's open-door policy to any
and every advisor who wanted to Ben
decir that included his eldest daughter
Ivanka and her husband Jared Kushner
that didn't sit well with Jovanka I
still don't understand why that nickname
has not caught on more it's gold and
they reportedly spent the intervening
months working to undermine Kelly
perfectly functioning White House it
worked as Trump himself bristled at
being managed and not being able to do
exactly what he wanted at exactly the
time he wanted to do it by the summer of
2018 it was clear Kelly was on borrowed
time Trump made it official in December
when he now Kelly was leaving at the end
of the year not clear that Kelly was
briefed on that now we all fought and by
we I mean Donald Trump that Nick airs a
Boy Wonder political strategist who had
been working as vice president Mike
Pence his chief of staff would quickly
fill the void left by Kelly but Ayers
wanted to get back to his native George
and we all know you can't be the White
House chief of staff from Georgia of
which brings us to where we are right
now which is nowhere we did it as in
Kelly is leaving around the first of the
year but we have no earthly idea and by
we again I mean Trump who might replace
him speaking of Donald Trump he's been
talking a lot lately about this very
chief of staff job quote I have at least
10 12 12 people that want it badly
he told Reuters in mid-december quote
I'm making a decision great people I
could do it immediately I mean no rush a
lot of people want it a lot of people
want it they want it badly and no Trump
isn't overcompensating here not at all
you're the one overcompensating not him
you're the puppet I won't go through all
10 12 of the potential candidates for
chief of staff because well there
probably are 10 or 12 candidates for
chief of staff so let's meet up Treasury
secretary Steve minuchin on the plus
side for minuchin he is someone who has
a long personal relationship with Trump
that's good and Trump respects minuchin
business acumen because he like the
president has made a lot of money that's
also good I'm the not so plus-sized
minuchin has already taken a ton of heat
in the media for his love of private
plane travel and there was the whole
thing with him and his wife louise
linton looking like worse badenov and
natasha not great
then there's Citizens United President
David bossy and this one is interesting
Boston was Trump's deputy campaign
manager in 2016 and even wrote a book
about that campaign called let Trump be
Trump now look it is what it is Bosque
has been kicking around conservative
fever swamps for decades he made his
name such as it is for working with
House Republicans during the impeachment
proceedings against Bill Clinton our
third option is Trump administration
jack-of-all-trades Mick Mulvaney that's
Mick not Nick
the former South Carolina congressman
currently RT has two jobs he's the boss
of the Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau and the director of the Office of
management and budget he's also one of
the very few people who has thrived
under Trump doing no small part to the
president believing that he's good on TV
the president watches a lot of TV now
what's the issue with Mulvaney that's
doesn't want the job quote he's not
interested in chief of staff a source
close to Mulvaney told CNN quote he has
been saying for almost two months that
he would be more interested in something
like Commerce or Treasury if that's
where the president needed him he and
last but certainly certainly not least
in our candidate search for chief of
staff is Chris Christie you know from
being the former governor of New Jersey
now no character arc in this reality TV
presidency has been more fascinating
than that of Christie
one of the first and only establishment
figures to endorse Trump's campaign
Christie thought he would have his pick
of cabinet spots except not because
Jovanka isn't a big fan now could this
be the ultimate redemption story the
prodigal son returns Trump does like
those sorts of narratives 2nd 3rd 4th
5th chances so I wouldn't rule Christie
out okay
we're down to it who will the president
pick honestly I don't really know well
with Mark Meadows now out of the running
Christie would be the best story and
Trump does love a good comeback tale
even though this is Trump and making
predictions about what he'll do is like
predicting what's next in the
relationship between cardi B and offset
and that is the very hip point we do
this every week twice stay tuned for new
episodes every Tuesday and Thursday
you